اكد قيادي في حزب المؤتمر الوطني السوداني
المنحل خروج عدد من اهم قيادي الحزب من
سجن كوبر بسبب تفجر الاوضاع الامنيه في
البلاد وتضم قائمه الخارجين مساعدين
بارزين سابقا للرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
ومسؤولين مهمين في نظامه وتبادل الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الاتهامات بتهيئه
الظروف لعمليه الخروج واستغلال الفوضى
لتحقيق اجندا سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات اين يمكن وضع خروج
قياديين بارزين من نظام الرئيس المعزول
البشير من السجون ضمن السياق العام
للتطورات الميدانيه التي يشهدها السودان
منذ اندلاع القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع كيف تعاملت اطراف الازمه مع هذا
المعطى في ظل حاله الفرز الحاد والدام
الذي تشهد البلاد والذي اختارت فيه قياده
الحزب المنحل مسانده الجيش ضد قوات الدعم
وما الذي ستؤول اليه التوازنات السياسيه
والميدانيه في البلاد بالنظر الى تجدد
القتال وغياب افق للتسويه السياسيه في
مشهد يعرف خلطا للاوراق وسطرهانات اقليميه
ودوليه تتعلق بالاحتمالات التي تنتظره
مستقبلا
[موسيقى]
اذا بعد ايام من اندلاع القتال بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع خيمت الفوضى
على البلاد وسط حاله مستحكمه من الاستقطاب
الذي زادت حدته بعوده حزب المؤتمر الوطني
المنحل الى الواجهه من خلال خروج قيادات
بارزه فيه من السجن بينها احمد هارون الذي
ادلى بتصريحات تضمنت دعم الحزب للجيش في
مواجهه قوات الدعم السريع ودعوه
السودانيين للالتفاف حوله الجيش السوداني
سارع بنقي بنفسه عن هذه التطورات مؤكدا ان
سلطه الاشراف على سجون البلاد تقع خارج
نطاق اختصاصه في موقف بدا ردا على موقف
لقوات الدعم السريع قالت فيه ان من وصفتهم
بقيادات الانقلابيين يرسمون خططا لاشعال
الحرب كغطاء لاخراج رموز نظام البشير من
السجن غير بعيد عن هذه الرؤيه
قالت قوى الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي
الى نظام البشير المعزول يريد استغلال
الاوضاع لاستعاده زمام الحكم واعاده
البلاد الى الاستبداد
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم عبر
الهاتف الرشيد المعتصم الباحث في مركز
الخرطوم للحوار من الخرطوم ايضا ينضم
الينا الباشا ضيق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ومن اسطنبول معنا حسن اسماعيل الوزير
الاعلامي والاتصالات الاسبق مرحبا بكم
جميعا سنبدا مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم الباشا
طبيق باعتقادك سيد الباشا ما هي الاهداف
من وراء عمليه اخراج هؤلاء المسؤولين في
النظام السابق من السجن
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله التحيه لك اختي
الكريمه والتحيه لمشاهدي قناه الجزيره
وتحيه للشعب السوداني وايضا التحيه الى
ضيوفك الكرام
السودان الان يمر بظروف خارجه جدا ويمر
بتطورات
قد تؤدي الى تفككه تماما وقد تؤدي الى
انهاء الدوله
يعني المركزيه منذ اندلاع هذه الحرب
الخامس عشر من هذا الشهر
وتطورت الاحداث الى ان وصلت الى خروج عدد
كبير جدا من
السجناء من سجون ولايه الخرطوم من سجن
الهدى ومن سجن سوما من سجن
يعني سجن
كوبر وبالتاكيد يعني هنالك ظروف يعني صعبه
جدا مره بالسجناء بالنسبه لانقطاع الغذاء
والكهرباء والمياه فاضطر عدد من السجناء
او كل السجناء بهذه السجون للخروج من هذه
يعني السجون وعلى هذه يعني يعني ما حدث
اخرج ايضا السجناء السياسيين وحسب ما
سمعناه من بيان اصدره
يعني احمد هارون بان كانت يعني هنالك ظروف
صعبه جدا وظروف قاسيه بالسجن طرطهم الى
الخروج من هذا
اخراج هؤلاء القياديين الذين يتبعون لنظام
للنظام السابق للنظام عمر البشير وراءه
فقط اهداف لوجستيه ام وراءه اهداف سياسيه
بعيده المدى
والله يا اختي الكريمه هنالك سيناريوهات
كثيره جدا تؤكد ان هنالك قد تكون يعني
توجد اهداف غير الاهداف المستوره بالظروف
التي مرت يعني بالسجناء ونسبه للبيان الذي
صدر ايضا يؤكد ان هنالك ترتيبات اخرى يعني
تريد بعض الجهات السياسيه
للزجه او صب الزيل على النار في المشهد
وتعقيد يعني المشهد المؤقت اصلا يعني
زيادته تعقيدا وهذا يؤكد ان الامر سوف
يزداد تعقيدا والمشهد سوف يزداد تعقيدا في
مقبل الايام بعد هذه يعني الحادثه
وايضا يعني
تقول سيد سيد الباشا يعني لنكون اكثر
لنحدد اكثر
ماذا تقول يعني انت تقول هناك من يريد ان
يصب الزيت على النار يريد ان يعقد المشهد
من الذي يريد ان يفعل ذلك من وراء هذه
العمليه وباي هدف باعتقادك باختصار لو
سمحت
سياسيه داخل داخل السودان او داخل
المؤسسات العسكريه تريد يعني يعني من خروج
هؤلاء يعني
المعتقلين السياسيين
لزياده المشهد تعقيدا على النار
ويعني البيان الذي استمعنا اليه كنا نريد
ان ان يذكر السيد يعني احمد هارون الظروف
التي دعتهم الى الخروج من المعتقل ويناشد
عموم الشعب السوداني
لايقاف هذه الحرب والجهات يعني المتصارعه
لايقاف هذه الحرب لكن ما سمعناهم بمناشده
يعني لعضويه لحزب محدد للوقوف مع طلب من
الاطراف انا افتكر ان هذا هو الذي يعني
يزيد
تعقيدا ويعقد الامور اكثر مما هي عليه
الان نحن
نريد شكل
من الاشكال فكرتك الرشيد المعتصم الدعم
السريع قوات الدعم السريع تقول ان الجيش
هو المستفيد من اطلاق سراح هؤلاء
القياديين التابعين لنظام البشير ما رايك
بهذا الاتهام
مساء الخير
تماما عن القوات التي تعدد على السجون
والسجون في ولايه الغرب هذا ثابت وانا
قابلت بعض المساجين الذين خرجوا من سجن
سوبا وقفته معه اكثر من عشرين دقيقه
هي التي اخرجتنا
خروج هؤلاء المساجين وشهادتهم بان قوات
الدعم سريعه
هي قوات الدعوه السريع تدير معركتها بشكل
يعني في
الفضاء الخارجي اكثر منها في الميدان يعني
الان لكن سيدي الرشيد السيد احمد هارون
عندما خرج يعني اصدر بيانا قال فيه بصراحه
انه دعى السودانيين الى دعم ومسانده الجيش
في هذه المعركه ان كان الامر كذلك ما
استفاده قوات الدعم السريع من اخراج هؤلاء
من السجون
سريع ربما اخطات التقدير يعني
ارادت خلط الاوراق وربما لا يباعد الخروج
هؤلاء
السياسي من سجن كوبر مباشره
بما سنوات الجزيره في يعني اعتقد وقنوات
الحدث والعربيه بدات تتكلم عن الارهاب
وربط هؤلاء هذه المجموعه الخارجي
صور لمجموعات عربيه
المقاتلين العرب في دول خارجيه ليست لها
علاقه بالسودان اصلا يعني والسولان يعني
وسطيون لا يوجد لا يوجد مقاتلون جانب في
هذه الحرب فربما كانت فيها رسائل للخارج
للشرق الاوسط
الاوروبيه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه بان
هناك حضور للارهابيين يعني حاضرين الحدود
من دول اخرى دخلوا السودان او سيقولون
وستكون هذه الشبكات مرتبطه بقيادات المطور
الوطني التي تجمع في السجون لها اربعه
سنين يعني بلا حول ولا قوه وفي هذا الامر
في اختيار كبير
وعشره قانون له
خلافات ومعروف كان يعني وكان له مواقف
صلبه ضد غايه الدعم السوريه محمد حمدان
يعني
فله خصومات سابقه وله تحفظات على على قوات
السريع ووجودها وهذا تحديدا يعني وهنا
المساله يعني كيف ان كانت هذه الخصومات
موجوده
كيف كيف اذا تقوم قوات الدعم السريع
باطلاق سراحهم
مستشاريه الدعم السرير حديث
يه في
القضايا وقد لاحظنا يعني كثير من هذه
المواقف في القرارات الخارجيه فهناك
ارتباط هناك عدم قدره المواقف بشكل جيد
واضح انه ليست هناك غرف يعني عمليات
متماسكه تدير المعركه الاعلاميه او
الخارجيه بطريقه ماضيه وفيها وعي وفيها
خيارات واضحه جدا
وفاتها الارتباط صاحب الدعم السريع في كله
مواقفه العسكريه والاعلاميه رغم ظهور
الاعلام الوطني
لكن في في كل الاحوال هناك ارتباك يعني
فهذا الارتباك في المواقف
وترتب عليه هذا الموقف الذي ربى يعني
المستشعرين قضيه تقوم فيها كاس سياسيه
خروجهاده المؤتمر الوطني
بعناصر خارجيه وانفتاح السودان لفتح
السودان
دعنا نسال سيد حسن اسماعيل سيد حسن
اسماعيل ضيفنا من اسطنبول وزير الاعلام
والاتصالات الاسبق ماذا يعني اخراج هؤلاء
المسؤولين تابعين للنظام السابق
مرحبا
سيد حسن هل تسمعني
طيب نعم سالتك سالتك ماذا يعني في هذه
المرحله من هذه المواجهات العسكريه بين
الطرفين خروج هؤلاء المسؤولين التابعين
للنظام السابق من السجن
هو من المسؤول قبل ان نقول المستفيد من هو
المسؤول عن خروج سته الف معتقل او سجين في
سجون السودان الخرطوبه المختلفه في سجل
الهدى وفي سجن كوبر وفي سجن النساء لا اظن
انه الاسلاميين الان لديهم سلطه يستطيعوا
ان يخرجوا كل هذه الاعداد ولا اظن ان
الاسلام لديهم مصلحه في اخراج اربع طيارين
محكومين في سجن الهدى يتبعون لي
المتمردين دعم الدعم السريع في الحقيقه قد
لا نجد اجابه في من الذي اخرج الاسلاميين
ولكن نستطيع ان نجابه ما هي الظروف التي
المعتقلين الاسلاميين من سجن ظروف واضحه
هي
الفوضى التي سالت الخرطوم في الايام
الماضيه انا كنت اتابع اوضاع البرتقلين في
سجن كوبر وقلت هذا في اكثر من منصه تم
اخراج 2000 سجين من كوبر محكومين بالاعدام
في قضايا مختلفه قضايا استلاء ايجار في
السلاح وتجار في المخدرات وغيرها اصبح
السجن غير امن على المعتقلين المعتقلين
السياسيين وخاطب المحاربون محاوله هؤلاء
الاخوه المعتقلين الدوله واداره السجون في
ضروره توفير مكان امن لهؤلاء المرتغلين
حتى لا يلحق بهم ضرر ولكن لم يتم هذا الى
ان جاء الحراس هؤلاء المعتقلون وطلبوا
منهم تامين انفسهم بانفسهم باعتبار اصبح
خاليا من الحراسه الرسميه
الجهه المستفيده من من اخراج الاسلاميه من
المعتقل قبل جهه المسات سيد حسن ليست هذه
هي الروايه التي قدمتها وزاره الداخليه
وزاره الداخليه السودانيه سيد حسن سيد حسن
هل تسمعني
سيد حسن سيد حسن اسماعيل هل تسمعني
وزاره الداخليه السودانيه قدمت روايه
مختلفه قالت صراحه ان قوات الدعم السريع
هي من عملت على اخراج هؤلاء من السجن اعني
القياديين التابعين للنظام السابق
انا قلت لك هذا الجهه الوحيده المستفيده
من اخراج الاسلامي في هذه الظروف هي الدعم
السريع في القوات المتمردين في الدعم
السريع وهذا بسبب محاوله الزجرهم في هذا
الصراع الدائري لانه معجزوا عن تعبئه
الشعر السوداني وعجزوا عن التحريض ضد
القوات المسلحه ويظنون اظن ضعيفا لان
الزنجبي الاسلامي ليستطيع ان يخيط بعض
العناصر وبعض اركان العمليه السياسيه وقد
يهيج بعض اركان العمليه الاخرى كما تفضل
احد ضيوفك الكرام وانا نسيت وان ارحب به
وترحيبا حاضرا
هذه هي المحاوله ولكن
نقطه ونسال بها السيد باشا الباشا الطبيق
ابقى معي سيد حسن سيد الباشا اذا يقول لنا
السيد حسن اسماعيل ان من يقف وراء اطلاق
سراح هؤلاء القياديين هي قوات الدعم
السريع لانها تريد تاجيج الاوضاع وهذا
اصلا
الاتهام الذي وجهته وزاره الداخليه التي
تشرف على السجون هو الاتهام نفسه وجه الى
قوات الدعم السريع ما رايك بذلك
هذه الروايه غير صحيحه هذه الروايه غير
صحيحه يعني ادلل على ذلك حتى السجناء
الذين خرجوا من السجن لم يذكروا ان القوات
الدعم السريع هي التي يعني اخرجتهم السريع
ليس يعني لا مصلحه باخراج السجناء من
السجن وجهه التي التي يعني مس
ؤوله للتامين
يعني السجناء هي وزاره الداخليه وهي الجهه
التي تدير الدوله الان لكن حتى بيان
الشرطه الذي يعني وزاره الداخليه الذي
اصدرته توجد في كثير من المغالطات تحدثت
عن سجن السجن مروان وسجن مروان لن تجري
فيه احداث امرها هي الشركه يعني الشركه
جنوب شرق مدينه الاوبيد لم تجري فيها
احداث اصلا ولما تحصل كاع اشتباكات وذكرت
في بيانه ان سجناء روابى ايضا خرجوا من
السجن فهذه الروايه الروايه الروايه يعني
فيها مغالطات كثيره جدا وهي يعني غير
صحيحه تماما يعني قوات الدعم السريع ليس
لها مصلحه في اطلاق اطلاق السجناء ماذا
تكسب قوات الدعم السريع من من خروج يعني
السجناء من السجون
سجناء
لقوات الدعم السريع كانوا مسجونين في هذه
السجون
هذا الكلام غير صحيح
وزاره الداخليه
الشعب المسلحه اصدرت بيان قالت السجن
المسؤوليه وزاره الداخليه فكيف يكون يعني
القوات الدعم السريعين من يعني من هذه
السجون الداخليه سيده الباشا اتهمت صراحه
قوات الدعم السريع باقتحام السجون واخراج
هؤلاء منها
وزاره الداخليه اتهمت صراحه قوات الدعم
السريع باقتحام السجون واخراج عدد من
المساجين التابعين لقوات الدعم السريع
وايضا اقتحام السجون واخراج عدد من
القيادات التابعه للنظام السابق
اين اين مزوليه الوزاره الداخليه وزاره
الداخليه لما انحصلت هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
الحرب كان يمكن لها يعني ان تروحي للسجناء
الى مناطق عامله يعني ولايات مثلا نهر
النيل ولايه الشماليه عدد من الولايات
نحن نتحدث عن الجهه التي قامت بهذا الامر
بغض النظر بغض النظر عن التقصير سيد
الباشا نحن نتحدث عن الجهه التي تقف وراء
هذا الموضوع
اقول لك بغض النظر عن التقصير ان كان هناك
تقصير من وزاره الداخليه كما تتهمها ولكن
نحن نتحدث عن من يقف وراء هذا الفعل
الذي تماما
ولكن هذه هذا سيناريو مسؤول منه
المسؤول الان يعني من اداره الدوله من هو
الان راس الدوله يعني الرئيس مجلس السياده
يعني وزاره الداخليه هي المسؤوله من هذا
لكن الدعم السريعه ليس لها علاقه باطلاق
سجناء ولا مصلحه لها بذلك سيدي الرشيد
المعتصم كيف تستفيد قوات الدعم السريع
ان كانت هي كما اتهمتها كما اتهمتها كانت
هي من اخرجت هؤلاء
القياديين التابعين للنظام عمر البشير من
السجون
قوات الدعم السريع ثابت انها تعدد على
السجون قبل تعدي قوات الدعم السريع
بالرصاص على المساجين
وكان هناك عدد كبير من الضحايا سقطوه يعني
كانت هناك ديما داخل السجن
وانا سمعت هذه الروايه مباشره يعني من
المساجين نفسهم يعني قبلت بعضهم وهو في في
يعني في بوابات السجون حقيقه يعني كنت
اتحرك بالعربي بالصدفه يعني
الاشاره الاولى التي يجب عنها
ولكن
اطلاقا من عدم قدره
وهي قوات شرطيه على الاستمرار في الحفاظ
على المساجين داخل السجون اعتبرونه هناك
مكسيما
مواد الغذائيه وكذا لكن كانت صامده حتى
هذه اللحظه مع انهاء يعني الدخول وعنصر
الرصاص وصعود ضحايا
الاوامر اصبح السيطره وهذه مسؤوليه اصلا
لم يتمكنوا من تحملها وسقط ضحايا ايضا من
من القوات السجون التي تتبع على السلطه
يعني بجانب السياسي لو سمحت
يجب ان اشير اليها
انه قوات الدعم السريع اختطفت عدد كبير من
العناصر الموجوده داخل هذه السجود سيد
الرشيد في الجانب السياسي كيف تستفيد قوات
الدعم السريع من هذه الحركه من هذه الخطوه
باعتبار ان هناك كثير من الناس لا يعني
لهم يعني عدائيات يعني مع مع مع ياسين
وربما هي في تقديراتها اما
في في خلقه يعني في خلط الاوراق وفي
موازين
والاعلام المضاف لانه هي حاولت تسوق بشكل
مباشر فتح السجون بانه هناك عناصر ارهابيه
قد تتلاحم مع هؤلاء السياسيين يعني
الامر هذا كان فيه في عمل اعلامي كثيف جدا
صاحب لحظات خروج عناصر المؤتمر الوطني
السجون لكن
فيه كثير من الخيال وهو هو اقرب لحلفاؤه
في مجموعه هذه المجموعات ايضا تفكر بطريقه
فيها
كثير من الخيال فيها كثير من الخيال وعدم
الواقعيه يعني
سيد حسن اسماعيل ضيفنا من اسطنبول قوات
الدعم السريع في معرضي الرد على الاتهامات
بانها هي من تقف وراء اخراج هؤلاء تقول ان
يعني تتهم قوات الجيش بان هي من قامت
باخراجهم وتتحدث عن ان هذا الدليل على ان
من يقف وراء تاجيج هذه المواجهات العسكريه
هم مجموعات تابعه للنظام السابق كيف ترد
على هذا الكلام
ولا يستقيم يعني لانه الذي اججج الصلاح
والذي حشد عشرات الالاف من المجندين من كل
ولايات السودان لاحتلال مطار الخرطوم
والاحتلال القياده والاحتلال مطار مروي
والاحتلال حتى
المصانع والمؤسسات التي تتبع للمواطنين
والذي اجد اصطلاح هو الذي يختصر منازل
السكان الان في بحره وفي الصباح
وياخذ حتى بعض السكان كراهين الذي اجلس
الصراع والذي حشد هذه الاله العسكريه
المجنونه كما قال لكي يفرض الاتفاق
الايطالي ويجبر القران على انفاس هذا
الاتفاق الايطالي اذا الذي عجز الصراع هو
الطرف الذي
بدا هذا الصراع وحاول اقامه انقلاب عسكري
على الاوضاع ليفرض موضوع او مشروع الاتفاق
المشروع الاتفاق الايطالي الاسلامي اختي
الكريمه
اعلان هم مستفيدين من ان يزيفهم في مثل
هذه هذا هذا الصراع الاسلامي منذ اربع
سنوات خصوم الذين وقفوا اماما قبل اربع
الحريه والتغيير من ثمانين الله اذا اصبحت
25 لازم تكون هناك تحتوي ثلاث احزاب ضعيفه
وثلاثه ضعيفه الان قطعت القوه الدعم
السريع باستدامها بالجدار جدار القوات
المسلحه ايضا الذين كانوا يريدون ابعاد
الاسلامي من المشهد السياسي في الاقليم
قامت هذه المعادله وتساقطت على راسهم الان
الاسلامي وهم يضعون رجب على
مشهد بتاع الصراع المباشر
يستفيدون الان من الصدام الذي يصفي خصوم
دون ان يتدخل هنا سؤال سيد حسن كيف
سيستفيدون كيف سيستفيدون من هذا الصدام
الذي تتحدث عنه ماذا يعني كيف سيترجم
ستترجم هذه الاستفاده للاسلاميين كما ذكرت
كيف ستترجم هذه الاستفاده قلت ان
الاسلاميين الان مستفيدون من هذا الصدام
الواقع كيف ستترجم هذه الاستفاده
هؤلاء كانوا يريد ان نفذوا انقلاب عسكري
ويروج له بان الانقلاب العسكري هدفه فرق
الاتفاق الايطالي فشلوا في هذا ووجدوا
انفسهم في مواجهه القوات المسلحه ظلوا
يحاولون تقليل هذه الخصومه يقول اننا ضد
القران ولكن وجدوا ان الشعب السوداني كله
يحرك ضدهم باعتبارا ان المعرفه ضد القوات
المسلحه معركه خاسره وهم يريد ان يتفادوا
هذا الفضاء الاعلامي باعتبار الفضاء خاتم
فيريد ان يزج اعلاميا فقط في الاسلاميين
حتى يحاولوا ان يعوضوا خسائر التعبئه ضد
القوات المسلحه باعتبار ان القوات المسلحه
هذه المؤسسه قوميه والاسلاميين مؤسسه
حزبيه يتفق ويختلف عليها لديها خصوم
ولديها منافسين ولديها اتباع ممكن ان تفرق
ضدها ولكن من الصعب جدا ان تحارب على
القوات المسلحه هم هذا الذي يقومون به هو
سلوك تعويضي في محاوله لتعويض خسائر
الخطابه والتعب والخسائر خطابهم مره قالوا
اكتشفوا ان الذي يتصدى لهم هي كل القوات
بكل اسلحتها وبكل اجنحتها وبكل ضباطها
وجنودها فكانت المعركه بالنسبه لهم خاسره
تعبويا
حاولوا ان يزجوا بالاسلاميين تعبوية ولكن
الشخصيات التي خرجت من السجن الشخصيات
التي خرجت من السجن بالامس مطلوبون
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هذا المعطى
باعتقادك كيف من شانه ان يؤثر على هذه
الخطوه داخليا ودوليا
فقاعات اعلاميه للتعبئه ضد نظام الحكومه
الانقاذ وهي الان اصبحت ليست جدوى الشعب
السوداني الان تجاوز هذا تجاوز هذا
الموضوع الشعب السوداني الان مشغول ومهموم
بالفشل المتراكم منذ اربع سنوات سودانيين
الان مهمومين بقضايا المعاش ومقات وقضايا
الطمانينه وقضايا الامن ان كان سيفتح في
هذا الموضوع باب المجازر والمذابح التي
ارتكبتها هو التمرد التي تتبع للفريقيه في
الخرطومه الان شكرا لك بعد
عدد يفوق 400 يفوق 400 شخص مدني قتلوا بدم
فارس
والاتصالات الاسبق من اسطنبول وشكرا موصول
لضيفينا الباشا طبيق الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي والرشيد المعتصم البحث في مركز
الخرطوم للحوار ايضا من الخرطوم نترككم
الان مع مشاهد مختلفه من السودان شكرا
لمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]